Dr Zakia is it permissible for one who
is unable to fast to feed one person for
30 days
or 30 people in one day as far as fidya
for a person who can't fast or is unable
to fast the Quran say in Surah Bak
chapter number two verse number
184 that if a person finds it difficult
to keep the fast or finds fast thing
with hardship then he can either fast or
he can
feed one indent person for every fast
that he has missed so if a
person who misses the full month of
Ramadan for example and if has to give
fidya he has both the options open he
either calls 30 people and feeds them
together so that compensates or gives
fidya for all the 30 days that the
person has missed or he can even give
one person fidya for 30 days and each
person should be given One S of the
staple food of that state of that
country one size equal 1 and a half
kilog approximately and both rulings are
there as it's mentioned in the ruling of
Abbas
inkari number six number
4505 in commentary of this verse of the
Quran Sur Bak CH 2 vers 184 it says that
those people who find it difficult
to fulfill the fast to complete the fast
they can either complete it or feed one
indent person and it says that these
type of people described are very old
men and women or those people who have
permanent disability or they have a
disease which makes them difficult to
fast and both type of fast as is given
in the Hadith of one of the sahabas by
the name of an bin Malik m i pleas with
him when he was old the Hadith says that
he cooked some food and called 30 people
and fed them together the full f for the
full month of Ramadan so here it shows
that you can either give cooked food
cook food for them and feed them well
whether it be breakfast whether it be
dinner whatever it is or the other
option is as is also agreed upon by Imam
ammed hbal Imam Shafi as well as some of
the
Maliki that you can also
give uncooked food to one person
for 30 days one person only give him
uncooked food for 30 days so that that
compensates or give the feed there for
the full month this is also agreed so
the choice is Al either feed one person
for 30 days or 30 people for one day
okay both is permissible fine thank you